We have a voicemail number and that number
is two one nine two. David P. Here is a
voicemail I received from a nurse about
covid and vitamin D, an important topic.
Let's take a listen here on the show dated
March the 9th. And you're talking about
the cases and the obesity, 77 percent of
those cases with severe morbid obesity.
I'm a dietitian practicing in St. Louis and
a critical illness recovery hospital where
we specialize in OK, so dietician, not nurse, just
to correct that, weaning patients off ventilators.
And I do nutrition support. And one of the things.
That you were touching upon was a vitamin D
and I have been doing investigation on my
own and every single patient that we have had
had been tested for vitamin D deficiency with an
alarming amount of those people having deficiency.
And there was a CDC YouTube post December the 10th
of twenty twenty, I believe it was right. Talking
about vitamin D and its correlation with outcomes
of covid 19 infection. And basically, if your
low status, you're more susceptible
to this, OK, and it got cut off there.
But the important word there is correlation.
There's a lot being looked at with vitamin D
and covid. But I think we have to be careful
about saying that supplementation of vitamin
D is protective or that once in the hospital,
giving people vitamin D helps them recover. And
one of the real questions is, does covid does
serious covid deplete vitamin D? When we find
the correlation, which is definitely there, a lot
of the people with the most serious covid cases
have low vitamin D. We might jump to a causal
relationship. It's conceivable that it's causal,
but it's reversed that one might have normal
vitamin D before getting covid and that falling
to serious covid depletes vitamin D. That's
one possibility, which is a reverse causation.
It also may be a correlation without causation. We
just have to be careful. It's being studied and I
want to know more about it. But I don't want to
go beyond what I've read on vitamin D and covid
in peer reviewed data. We have a great bonus show
for you today. Burger King sent out a tweet that
created a real problem, which is women belong
in the kitchen. What they meant was they want
more women chefs in the world. It sounded very,
very different. Burger King having to correct
the record. Alaska has opened covid vaccination to
16 plus. It's incredible what Alaska is doing on
vaccination, particularly given how rural much of
Alaska is. And we will also talk about the reality
of people on unemployment benefits. Many on the
right believe people are living the high life on
unemployment benefits, including with the enhanced
unemployment provided through covid relief. This
is not the case. This is not the case. And
we will talk about that and more on today's
bonus show. It's actually a good bonus show today.
This one may get an award, which we will give out,
of course, or get instant access to the bonus
show by becoming a member at Join Pakman Dotcom.